hey Gary its Ryan Charleston from
oppressive how are you good god there's
a lot of talk about agencies and the
role they play in native advertising
storytelling obviously that's what
they're good at yep
and how publishers are kind of
encroaching on that territory yeah
doesn't this though put them back sort
of at the center who the baby agencies
listen very honestly and I said it when
I was in the wine business I talked I
sat in front of a room like this in Napa
with a hell of a lot more people I said
in 1999 I said listen I'm starting to do
a lot more business on this thing called
ecommerce that you all think is stupid
and I'm like you better not make the
mistake of me having more value than you
all of you in this room should start
selling your wine direct-to-consumer
because if you do you're gonna keep a
hell of a lot more of the money to me at
vaynermedia my agency does not bring
value to my client we should be out of
business so should everybody so the
answer is you can't just say agency
it's like saying social network some
suck [ __ ] and don't deserve the business
some are good and are bringing more
value because it's really funny that's
another thing that I've learned about
this agency thing since I decided to
start one I can't believe all ours all
ours are treated equal I get on the
phone with procurement and they're like
well this I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like that company is [ __ ]
like I'm doing good work and I get more
value for my hour if it's quality and so
I think that's what it comes down to I
think that I think that publishers
should play very honestly I'll give you
an algal really rogue on you on this
question so if you look at data which I
love so much if you look at data in the
19 in 1982 the percentage of MBAs that
went to CPG clients versus retail that
went to Proctor and when all the way up
into the early 2000s everybody went to
Procter and PepsiCo and companies
somewhere around 99 2000 you started
seeing an interesting shift where a lot
of people started going to retail and
more importantly the creme de la creme
were starting to go retail so over the
last thirty years the amount of money
that brands have put into working media
versus trade has been stunning if you
look at the money that retailers like
Kmart and Woolworths and all those guys
got from brands in 1982 was nothing it
was an afterthought when you start
looking at the money today that the
Walmarts of the cost
and what now amazon is asking for the
trade dollars it's stunning at the same
time those companies those Walmart's and
Costco's the amount of private labels
they had 30 years ago would non-existent
today there's substantial parts of the
business so brands are funding their
competitor their competitor isn't you
know you know libros competitor isn't
necessarily Cincinnati it's more
Arkansas than they think and soon to be
Seattle right so here is where I'm going
with this because you don't know why the
[ __ ] I'm saying this somewhere around
the time when the talent started going
to the retailer instead of the brand
something interesting happened I
actually think that the smartest brands
out there when they start winning the
creative battle and all of a sudden the
best creatives aren't going to startups
and maybe aren't going to fancy-schmancy
agencies but they're going to bran
direct and they become the best
storytellers I think there's a major
battle between the publisher the brand
and the agency and who's gonna win is
who's ever good at it right and so
they'll be a flushing out there's a lot
of below-average work out there at the
scale that's gonna be fleshed out
because the innovations on people are
paying attention I think the number one
creative chick right now that is coming
out of school today may want to go to a
fancy agency here on some you know
Madison Avenue I think in you know three
four or five seven years it's gonna be
interesting where that gal might want to
go and it may want to be brand direct
every person every business every human
in here every brand smart what everybody
everybody is in the content war now
we're all in the content business and
it's all gonna come to a head and you
know quality is gonna win and whoever's
got the right strategy is gonna win